this is an age where disruptions are
taking place at such a rapid Pace where
the company can go from leading to
bleeding at the blink of an eye it's
really about designing to be agile
designing to anticipate the unknown
[Music]
almost all solutions to problems out
there have a Technology based to it this
program is geared towards Executives
leveraging technology to drive change
across organizations from strategic
Vision development Innovation scaling
Excellence this program will make me a
better leader this program exposes
Executives to the cutting-edge tools
that are available out there for example
design thinking or behavior design The
Cutting Edge Frameworks concepts best
practices out there when we brainstorm
we put up an idea and whoever can shoot
down the idea first is the genius in the
room and through design thinking you
know really picked up some great ways to
do brainstorming better how do we get
more rapid in terms of prototyping and
testing things rather than spending six
months kind of building something only
to get the feedback after we launch it
something as simple as understanding
that we make decisions generally 95 of
the time based on emotion and Instinct
it's very fundamental and will
absolutely carry value going forward in
probably all aspects of my life it's the
All-Star content from the GSB no doubt
and then on top of it it's in Silicon
Valley in one week you really do get to
kind of capture the essence of what it's
like here one of the great aspects of
this program is that we have time for
discussion so that others who have
similar problems can learn from one
another
it is a completely immersive week and
it's joyfully intense changes that are
going to take place in the future in
organizations in the marketplace are
going to be led by cios I think all
these skills will allow more and more
cios to sit at the table with other
c-level Executives as being really
critical and driving innovation in the
company